la séance est ouverte
le compte rendu analytique de la
présidentielle séance a été distribuée
nous n'avons pas reçu l'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je n'en vois pas le procès sous les
réserves d'usage madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues l'or du
jour appelle les questions d'actualité
au Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmis en direction Public Sénat et
notre site internet chacun sera attentif
au respect de valeur qui sont Bordeaux
essentielles le respect des uns et des
autres et le respect du temps de parole
et je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Jérémy maquis pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste j'avais la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues nous ne
minimisons pas ce qui se passe à Mayotte
depuis quelques temps les violences les
agressions au contraire la détresse de
la population et l'insécurité qui règne
sont insoutenables notamment pour les
plus faibles pour nous la seule solution
envisageable pour résoudre cette spirale
infernale est une réponse républicaine
aujourd'hui votre réponse est uniquement
répressive elle pas digne des valeurs
républicaines détruire des bidonvilles
expulser des sans-papiers ne permettront
pas de rétablir la paix au contraire
cela permet un vice-président du conseil
départemental de Mayotte de dire
tranquillement sur une chaîne de
télévision que peut-être il faut en tuer
quelques heures sur le fond cette élu
s'attaque violemment en valeur
républicaines et l'absence de réaction
plus haut niveau de l'État nous laisse
un goût amer l'opération one bouchou que
vous avez déclenché est une atteinte
assez droit on attendait la France de la
France une réponse respectueuse du droit
et de nos valeurs et non qu'elle se
comporte comme chef de bornes en effet
vous démolissez des bidonvilles où
vivent des Comoriens et des Mahorais
parfois très jeunes sans leur proposer
de solution de logement digne ne pas
comprendre que les Comores sont à la
fois plusieurs îles avec des statues
différents mais en même temps avec un
seul et unique peuple c'est conduire
dans une impasse tout tentative de
résolution d'ailleurs le droit
international est clair sur le sujet
pour l'ONU c'est un archipel constitue
un même pays des enfants grandissent
sans leur famille au nom du droit du sol
et se retrouve à survivre au quotidien
la République doit s'incarner dans ce
cas là de meilleurs à Mayotte et pas
seulement sur le volet répressif alors
que les droits les plus essentiels comme
l'accès à l'éducation à la santé à
l'alimentation un logement digne ne sont
pas assurés monsieur le ministre la
détresse sociale est grande quant en
dehors des réponses répressives à nous
vous apporter des réponses sociales à la
hauteur des attentes des mahoraises et
des Mahorais je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
monsieur Gérald Darmanin vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs Center monsieur
sénateur permettez-moi de vous dire que
tout est scandaleux dans les propos que
vous venez de tenir
vous venez de vous asseoir sur la
Constitution de la République je vous
rappelle que c'est ces assemblées le
président Chirac qui inscrit Mayotte
dans la Constitution vous venez de dire
que Mayotte n'était pas française mais
qu'elle était comorienne c'est à dire
que pour un représentant du peuple
français ou siège ici des représentants
de Mayotte vous partez du principe que
la France n'est pas chez elle à Mayotte
alors que les maorilles ont choisi par
deux référendum dans les années 70
monsieur le sénateur alors même que vous
participiez à d'autres gouvernements
dans votre partie des années après ils
ont choisi librement de rester français
vous venez de dire
que la France se comporte en chef de
monde qu'on nous interpellons au périls
des policiers des gendarmes tous les
jours et toutes les nuits justement des
bandes criminelles et c'est la première
objectif de cette opération on vous chou
que nous lançons à la demande de tous
les éléments et même du responsable elle
est fit de Mayotte ça mérite quand même
d'être souligné je peux vous envoyer ce
communiqué de presse que vous n'avez
manifestement pas eu l'occasion de dire
dans votre question d'actualité oui
monsieur le sénateur ce que le
gouvernement fait ici à Mayotte c'est ce
qu'il aurait dû faire depuis très
longtemps interpeller les bandes casser
et la spirale incroyable des mangas
certes des habitats illégaux où vivent
des enfants des vieillards des personnes
handicapées qui n'ont ni haut ni
l'électricité ni gaz et oui oui monsieur
le sénateur l'immigration irrégulière
est inacceptable dans votre département
comme à Mayotte c'est à dire dans toute
la France
[Applaudissements]
quelques secondes je ne dis pas que la
France monsieur le ministre je ne dis
pas que la France doit pas agir ce que
je dis c'est qu'il y a des conditions
aujourd'hui qui aggravent la situation
le visa Balladur par exemple en est un
parfait exemple aujourd'hui qui ne fait
que aggraver pour le coup ce fossé qui
existe entre les différentes
îles comoriennes et je crois qu'il est
grand temps de la projet merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue tany
Mohamed Souali pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
depuis quelques jours l'Hexagone
découvre avec effroi les immenses
difficultés auxquelles le département de
Mayotte est confronté immigration
gestion de l'eau assainissement logement
insalubre la liste est longue les
chiffres les plus difficiles à accepter
à mon sens sont ceux qui touchent notre
jeunesse laquelle représente plus de la
moitié de la population un système de
rotation inédit et inacceptable lié à un
manque crucial d'infrastructure entraîne
75% de décrochage scolaire quand le
niveau national est de 10% les problèmes
s'accumulent et s'amplifient depuis des
décennies c'est le cas de l'insécurité
alimenté par la multiplication des gangs
et l'immigration illégale et massive une
situation je le répète avec force ici
sans égal dans le reste du territoire
français l'opération en bouchou que vous
avez eu le courage d'engager monsieur le
ministre et une réponse forte très
attendue par la population est née ni
honteuse ni glorieuse et il est
nécessaire pour réaffirmer l'autorité de
l'État et protéger nos compatriotes de
Mayotte elle tranche avec l'inertie de
ces dernières années je veux ici rendre
hommage à nos forces de l'ordre à leur
engagement sans faille ou emboutchou qui
signifie reprise en schémaoré se fixe
comme objectif de restaurer le droit à
la sécurité mais demain il faudra aussi
envisager et un bouchon de l'éducation
de la santé de l'Aménagement et du
Logement monsieur le ministre alors que
cette opération vient à peine de débuter
les Mahorais sont inquiets par la
suspension des reconduites à la
frontière vers les Comores ainsi que par
certaines décisions judiciaires qui ne
sont pas toujours comprise quelle mesure
supplémentaire entendez-vous déployer
pour que cette promesse de retour à
l'ordre républicain soit un succès
pour vous répondre la parole est à le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des
outre-merdes
monsieur le sénateur d'abord je veux
dire que c'est à votre initiative et à
celle des élus mahorais que l'État sous
l'autorité de la première ministre a
décidé d'engager à Mayotte des moyens
sans précédent des moyens sans précédent
pourquoi d'abord pour maîtriser la
démographie le problème de cette
magnifique
île de Mayotte qui pourrait être plus
belle encore que sont les Bahamas ou les
Seychelles vous le savez mieux que
personne avec ce lagon incroyable c'est
qu'il est ce territoire déstabilisé par
une population qui malheureusement fait
dériver des services publics quel qu'ils
soient ça explique de la sécurité le
service public de l'éducation je
rappelle qu'à Mayotte vous le savez les
enfants quand ils vont à l'école vont à
l'école qu'une demi-journée par jour
parce qu'il n'y a pas assez
d'établissements scolaire pour suivre la
démographie qui arrive déstabiliser en
santé 80% des enfants qui naissent à
l'hôpital de Mamoudzou ne sont pas nés
de Maoré et en partie oriente chaque
année sont accouchés par les
sapeurs-pompiers de l'île de Mayotte ce
qui montre une difficulté bien sûr de
sanitaires pour notre pays difficulté
sociale de manière générale du fait de
cette démographie donc d'abord il s'agit
de la reprise de la sécurité je l'ai dit
vous savez sur les 60 objectifs de la
police judiciaire 22 ont déjà été
interpellés présentés en 15 jours au
service de Monsieur le gardeesseau nous
espérons qu'ils vont appliquer des
décisions de justice qui sont prononcées
qui sont fermes entre 7 et 10 ans de
prison pour la plupart des personnes que
nous avons interpellé ensuite la
destruction des mangas le ministre du
Logement nous a mis à disposition tous
les relogements possibles et
contrairement à ce que j'entends
évidemment que tous les mineurs non
seulement ne sont pas reconduits à la
frontière mais en plus sont logés et
accueillis dans les services de
l'enfance merci le département et la
secrétaire d'État à l'enfance et oui
nous luttons contre l'immigration
irrégulière Sri Lanka Madagascar Afrique
des Grands Lacs certes tous déstabilisés
pour des raisons pour une autre et bien
évidemment les cow-boys avec lequel nous
continuons à discuter nous continuerons
notre travail et je laisserai sous
l'autorité de la première ministre les
policiers les gendarmes autant d'autant
qu'il le faudra à Mayotte pour que
Mayotte se sente comme n'importe quel
département français
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Rémi
Féraud pour le groupe socialiste
écologique et républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre quelques jours après votre
passage en force pour imposer la réforme
des retraites et sa promulgation par le
Président de la République même l'agence
de notation Fitch assortie sa casserole
en abaissant la note de la France
certes et même si leurs appréciations
ont des conséquences pour notre part
nous ne révérons pas les agences de
notation mais toute votre action elle
est faite pour satisfaire leurs
exigences reconnaissez ainsi que votre
politique n'est pas seulement injuste
elle manque aussi d'efficacité et elle
crée de l'inquiétude or vos annonces en
matière budgétaire ne sont pas
rassurantes non plus parce que derrière
le flou et les contradictions de votre
programme de stabilité se cache à
l'évidence des mesures d'austérité sur
la solidarité et les services publics
parce que vous parlez de revues des
dépenses mais vous refusez obstiné toute
mesure de justice fiscale votre méthode
brutale conduit à une telle crise
sociale et démocratique qu'elle inquiète
même les marchés financiers alors il
vous faut aujourd'hui changer de
gouvernance pour redonner une
perspective au pays et un espoir aux
Français monsieur le ministre allez-vous
vraiment attendre 100 jours pour prendre
acte de l'impasse dans laquelle et le
gouvernement allez-vous vraiment
attendre 100 jours pour changer
radicalement de méthode et donner à
votre action un nouveau cap qui soit
plus juste mais qui soit aussi plus
clair et plus efficace
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'économie des finances et
de
industrielle et numérique Monsieur Bruno
Le Maire merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Sénateur
je vois que vous lisez des bons auteurs
madame la scène actrice
il y a un peu d'un conséquence
je vois votre sourire il y a un peu d'un
conséquence
dans votre question monsieur le sénateur
à la fois vous regrettez la décision de
l'agence dotation Fitch dont nous
prenons acte avec la première ministre
et dans le même temps vous nous dites
qu'il ne faudrait pas réduire les
dépenses publiques réduire la dette et
rétablir les finances publiques de la
France nous nous sommes conséquents nous
avons en 2017 et 2018 rétablit les
finances publiques de notre pays nous
sommes revenus sous les 3% de déficit et
nous sommes sortis la procédure pour
déficit excessif ensuite nous avons eu à
faire face à trois crises successives la
crise des gilets jaunes la crise du
covid et la crise de l'inflation et à
chaque fois nous avons pris les mesures
de protection nécessaire pour éviter les
conséquences sur nos compatriotes sur
les salariés sur l'emploi sur
l'industrie sur les entreprises de notre
pays maintenant que nous sortons de
cette période de crise et j'ai bon
espoir que nous sortions inflationniste
dans le courant de cet été nous revenons
à la normale il est temps de rétablir
les finances publiques de la France nous
avons engagé avec la première ministre
une revue des dépenses publiques je
tiendrai des Assises des finances
publiques au début du mois de juin pour
regarder comment aller plus loin dans la
réduction à dépenses rétablissement de
nos finances publiques nous allons
accéder le désendettement de la France
et nous ne faisons pas ça pour quelques
agences de notation que ce soit nous le
faisons pour les français pour
l'indépendance de la France et pour la
souveraineté nationale
monsieur Ferro
monsieur le ministre j'ai pas lu tous
les derniers romans mais j'ai lu
l'appréciation de Fitch et elle conteste
votre méthode sans forcément contester
vos objectifs moi je vois que vous
risquez d'aggraver encore votre
politique et de maîtriser les dépenses
publiques en sacrifiant encore davantage
la solidarité les services publics les
investissements d'avenir et encore une
fois sans prélever leur juste
contribution sur les plus riches sur les
grandes entreprises sur les
multinationales comme le demande les
Français après cette période si
douloureuse et si injuste voilà ce que
j'avais à vous répondre et j'espère que
nous pourrons avancer ensemble monsieur
le président
Jean-Claude Roquier pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur lemise
dans les cultures et de la souveraineté
alimentaire depuis plusieurs mois la
filière noire traverse une crise sans
précédent avec des cours qui s'efforent
de près de 3-0 le kilo nécessaire pour
couvrir les frais de production les noix
partent actuellement quand elles partent
au prix de 50 centimes 1 € le kilo
pourquoi cette crise elle est liée à la
conjonction d'une surproduction mondiale
et en France d'une chute 30% de la
consommation de noix en magasin l'anneau
en n'étant pas considéré en période
d'inflation comme un produit essentiel
malgré ses qualités nutritionnelles
reconnues l'inquiétude garde les
producteurs qui soient du lot de la
Dordogne ou de la Corrèze avec la noix
du Périgord la vallée de la de l'Isère
avec la noix de Grenoble ou d'ailleurs
avec des problèmes de trésorerie
[Musique]
pour vous répondre la parole au ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur Marc fenault vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatum monsieur le
Président Ruquier merci de votre
question sur une filière c'est assez
paradoxal au fond parce que on est dans
une filière qui est plutôt en crise de
croissance
ce que vous avez décrit c'est plutôt une
filière sur lequel la demande mondiale
est plutôt croissante du fait d'ailleurs
de ce qu'on appelle le phénomène du
snacking et en disant plus 50% de
surface en noir et donc c'est ça aussi
qu'on a sous les yeux c'est une crise de
croissance dans un contexte d'une
surproduction cette année de compétition
climatique et d'une condition de marché
qui crée ces conditions-là je rappelle
que la France et le premier exportateur
européen le quatrième exportateur
mondial et c'est bien là-dessus qu'il
faut qu'on essaie aussi de travailler
pour conforter cette souveraineté qu'on
a sur cette filière sur cette filière de
noix alors me demander les réponses
qu'on peut apporter vous en avez cité un
certain nombre la première c'est sans
doute un travail que nous devons faire
en termes de communication y compris
avec la grande distribution ça c'est à
l'intérieur de nos frontières pour mieux
valoriser la loi faire en sorte qu'on
puisse déstocker ce qu'on a entre autres
cette année deuxièmement c'est un
travail que nous devons faire à
l'extérieur de nos frontières
européennes et mondiales pour valoriser
encore vous avez indiqué les signes de
qualité qui sont les nôtres pour faire
en sorte que là aussi on puisse
développer les choses deux on a des
outils de régulation et je l'ai dit aux
acteurs de la filière que j'ai rencontré
il y a un peu plus d'un mois de se
saisir des programmes opérationnels
puisque à leur demande ils peuvent
intégrer ces programmes opérationnels et
ça permet d'intégrer des mesures de
retrait et donc des mesures de
régulation de marché pas il me semble
que c'est un élément important et donc
je les recontacterai aussi pour leur
dire qu'ils peuvent se rapprocher de
France agrimaire il me semble que c'est
un élément important il faut aussi que
nous travaillons à plus moyen et long
terme avec la filière avec les
producteurs de fruits et légumes pour
regarder sur le comme les surfaces
continuent à augmenter comment stabilise
le marché c'est sans doute les éléments
de communication et puis troisième
élément c'est le travail que nous
faisons sous le plan de souveraineté
légumes la filière fait partie de cette
grande famille des fruits et légumes
même si ça là c'est plutôt les coques
pourrait-on dire et donc on va
travailler avec eux à la fois sur les
questions phytosanitaires comment on
arrive à réduire les produits et en même
temps garder de la compétitivité et par
ailleurs comment on fait en sorte
d'ouvrir des nouveaux marchés donc la
communication les outils de régulation
sur les stocks la vocation exportatrice
qui font conforter et deuxièmement le
plan de filière fruits et légumes
tu es le président recul
la parole est notre collègue Daniel
Breuillet pour le groupe écologie
solidarité territoire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre l'eau est un bien
commun et sa gestion durable une
nécessité vitale aujourd'hui les
sécheresses sont redoutables et de plus
en plus brutales et dérèglements
climatique s'accélèrent et notre
adaptation n'est pas à la hauteur parce
qu'elle n'intègre pas suffisamment
l'articulation entre les interventions
d'urgence nécessaire et les
interventions structurelles qui sont
elles indispensables c'est pourquoi je
m'adresse à vous monsieur le ministre
Bruno Le Maire depuis plusieurs jours le
maire de la ville de Grigny dans
l'Essonne discute avec l'usine locale de
Coca-Cola pour que l'entreprise arrête
de puiser de l'eau dans la nappe
phréatique en Isère rester
microélectronique qui a bénéficié de 2,3
milliards d'euros d'argent public va
consommer près de 29.000 m3 jours
l'équivalent de la consommation d'une
ville de cent mille habitants en
Bretagne l'installation de l'usine
Bridor fait l'objet de contestation par
sa consommation de terres agricoles et
le manque de ressources en eau pour
chacun de ces des solutions de
réutilisation et de recyclage de l'eau
existe les procédés sont coûteux et sans
volonté et exigences politiques sans
conditionnalité des aides à la gestion
de l'eau la gestion de l'eau passera
toujours au second plan monsieur le
ministre vous supprimez la CVAE et
renforcer les aides fiscales mais quelle
contrepartie exigez-vous pour que les
projets de réindustrialisation soient
économe en eau et en ressources
naturelles monsieur le ministre nous
soutenons la réindustrialisation
utile de notre pays car on peut être
écologiste et pour l'industrie mais
peut-on être libéral et soucieux de
l'écologie combien de milliards
consacrez-vous à cette exigence de
réindustrialisation compatible avec le
dérèglement climatique
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Christophe Bechet ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur
puisque vous avez
vous même dans votre intervention
expliquer qu'on pouvait être écologiste
et en faveur de la réindustrialisation
je vous prends au mot et je vous réponds
pendant trop d'années ça n'est pas une
critique qui est ciblée contre qui que
ce soit parce que malheureusement elle
pourrait concerner beaucoup au cours de
ces dernières décennies pendant trop
d'années on a fait de l'écologie grâce à
la désindustrialisation
c'est à dire qu'on a baissé nos
émissions puisqu'on a fermé des usines
et que dans le même temps maman on dû
diminuions nos émissions nationales on
augmentait notre empreinte puisqu'on
s'est retrouvé à importer des produits
qui venaient de l'extérieur donc dire
que la réindustrialisation permet de
retrouver des circuits courts et de
s'inscrire dans cette logique c'est non
seulement quelque chose de souhaitable
mais c'est exactement le chemin que nous
devons suivre et ce sera au cœur du
projet de loi industrie verte qui sera
présenté par Bruno Le Maire qui est
évidemment accompagné par le ministère
de la transition écologique dans le même
temps bien sûr il y a des défis dans
cette réindustrialisation et dans ces
défis il y a la gestion des ressources
naturelles il y a celle qui concerne le
foncier disponible il y a celle qui
concerne la formation et les hommes et
les femmes qu'il faudra faire en sorte
d'orienter et il y a bien entendu la
question de l'eau
sur l'eau la trajectoire globale elle
est simple c'est celle de la sobriété
quelle que soit les usages ce que disent
les rapports du GIEC et que l'eau dont
nous disposons sa moins nombreuse
puisque l'augmentation des températures
augmentera les vapo transpiration et que
parallèlement la végétation en absorbera
une part plus élevée et c'est exactement
ce qui explique que au-delà de cette
trajectoire de sobriété nous devons
optimiser les usages dans les
optimisations d'usage vous citez Grigny
qu'une usine Coca-Cola pompe dans la
nappe phréatique il y a des alternatives
technologiques qui permettent
aujourd'hui avec des procédés de
réutilisation avec des dispositifs sur
place de pouvoir éviter ce type de
choses je ne peux pas croire que vous
ayez terminé votre intervention en
disant que vous étiez favorable à la
réindustrialisation et que dans le même
temps confronté à la réalité de certains
projets qui permettent de créer des
emplois en proximité et d'éviter une
empreinte carbone désastreuse vous vous
abritiez ensuite derrière forcément les
difficultés mais les chemins que nous
avons à construire pour rendre possible
cette réindustrialisation verte de notre
pays
monsieur le ministre en l'absence de
réponse du ministre de l'Industrie je
voudrais vous dire que nous prenons la
relocalisation depuis longtemps car
c'est une condition de la transition
écologique indispensable mais
l'industrie ne doit pas seulement être
décarbonée comme vous le revendiquez
elle doit être réellement verte
c'est-à-dire socialement utile
soutenable et économe en eau les
arbitrages sur les prélèvements d'eau
doivent être transparents décidés
démocratiquement et exigeant en termes
de modération des prélèvements pour
préserver les milieux
la parole est au président Claude
malurey pour le groupe Les Indépendants
Républiques et territoires
après l'incendie des quarts de
gendarmerie il y a un mois à
Sainte-Souline le 1er mai à Paris ce
sont les policiers eux-mêmes qui ont été
transformés en torche vivante semaine
après semaine l'ultra gauche et les
Black Blocs programme l'escalade avec
pour objectif l'insurrection
balayer la réforme des retraites le
guide suprême de la France soumise à
Poutine vêtue d'un manteau de cuir qui
aurait fait fureur dans les années 30
nous a expliqué lundi avec les gestes de
la main et du menton en vogue à l'époque
qu'il fallait je cite mettre à bas la
mauvaise République ce n'est pas un
énième dérapage verbal hier à
l'Assemblée un de ses soucistre s'est
chargé de l'exégèse lors des questions
au gouvernement il commence à
s'adressant à vous madame la Première
ministre policier brûlé les coupables
c'est vous il continue la Cinquième
République permet d'agir sans le peuple
et contre lui elle n'est plus légitime
ABA Macron est la mauvaise République
vive la Constituante et la Sixième
République le 14 juillet vous aurez
votre prise de la Bastille cette névrose
obsessionnelle de ce croire chaque jour
le 13 juillet 89 comme d'autres se
prennent pour Napoléon pour ressembler
le mériter qu'une consultation à
Sainte-Anne mais méfions-nous
les émeutes les émeutes et parfois même
les insurrections souvent étaient
déclenchées par des dingues et je
conseille à ceux qui ne l'ont pas encore
fait de ce documenter sur le Sixième
République que nous propose la France
irrécupérable la cinquième serait vite
regrettée comme un modèle de démocratie
cette tenaille entre les violences dans
la rue et la zadigestion de l'Assemblée
nationale qui dure depuis des mois est
en train peu à peu de saper la confiance
des Français dans leurs institutions et
de dissoudre lentement le respect pour
l'ordre républicain dans ce contexte je
veux rendre hommage aux jeunes policiers
de 27 ans brûlés avant-hier est toujours
hospitalisé mais aussi aux 450 membres
des forces de l'ordre blessés depuis ce
jour-là et aux 1083 blessés depuis le
début de l'année en accomplissant leur
mission et vous posez ma question
comment adapter notre Saunal juridique
pour mieux protéger nos forces de
l'ordre face au voyou organisés
parasitant désormais toutes les
manifestations avec pour seul but de
casser du flic
on vous répond la parole est à madame la
Première ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président Claude madurée lundi à
l'occasion de la Journée internationale
des travailleurs de nombreuses
manifestations ont eu lieu dans notre
pays dans la très grande majorité des
villes grâce à la responsabilité des
organisations syndicales et à
l'engagement des préfets et des forces
de l'ordre les cortèges ont pu défiler
sans heurt et les idées s'exprimer
malheureusement vous l'avez souligné
monsieur le Président une fois de plus
dans plusieurs villes comme Paris Lyon
Nantes ou Rennes des casseurs décidaient
à en découdre avec les forces de l'ordre
ce sont infiltrés dans les cortèges et
ont provoqué des violences parfois très
graves
et en disant ces mots je pense aux
commerçants aux élus aux habitants qui
ont découvert hier matin leur vitrine
leur mobilier urbains ou leur voiture
avec de lourds je pense aux manifestants
que c'est casseurs mettent en danger
sans hésiter je pense au parlementaire
dans les domiciles ont été visés aux
militants dont certains ont été pris à
partir je pense enfin et bien sûr à nos
forces à nos forces de l'ordre attaquer
dans plusieurs villes dans un
déchaînement de violence plus de 400
policiers et gendarmes ont été blessés
lundi certains gravement et la France
entière a été choquée par les images du
policier grièvement blessés par un
cocktail Molotov alors je veux dire aux
policiers et aux gendarmes ma solidarité
et mon soutien celui de mon gouvernement
et je n'en doute pas celui de tous les
élus dans cette hémicycle et je le
répète devant vous les auteurs de ces
exactions doivent être
identifiés et traduits en justice
aujourd'hui certains continuent à mettre
en cause les forces de l'ordre excusez
les casseurs
occulter les violences c'est l'honneur
de nos policiers et de nos gendarmes de
protéger la liberté d'expression la
liberté de manifester nous sommes et
nous resterons à leur côté toutes les
mesures susceptibles de renforcer leur
protection dans le respect des libertés
publiques seront étudiées monsieur le
Président vous évoquez également les
nouvelles outrances du leader de la
France insoumise elle s'inscrivent dans
une remise en cause permanente de nos
institutions elles sont une nouvelle
étape pour saper la confiance de nos
concitoyens dans notre démocratie
ah bah la mauvaise République dit-il
chacun le sait bien pour Jean-Luc
mélench Mélenchon la seule bonne
République c'est lui pour notre part
nous sommes et nous resterons du côté de
la République et de l'ordre républicain
je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue le
président François Noel buffet pour le
groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Miss de l'intérieur
j'ai le ministre vous portez depuis
quelques jours une opération d'envergure
à Mayotte de lutte contre l'immigration
irrégulière dans ce territoire un peu
particulier dont il a été rappelé tout à
l'heure par l'autre collègue tenima
mezouali les circonstances de vide
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens 50% de la
population est étrangère et 50% de cette
population est en situation irrégulière
depuis de nombreuses années nous
constatons pardon une augmentation des
actes de violence de toute nature
aujourd'hui dans votre opération vous
heurtez à la non réadmission d'une
partie de ces gens en situation
régulière en juin ou en Comores voilà
comment où en êtes-vous aujourd'hui des
accords de réadmission
de la part de ce pays de ceux que nous
tentons d'expulser de Mayotte car sans
réussite et sans obtention de ces fameux
laisser passer consulaires devenus
aujourd'hui beaucoup trop célèbre je
pense que l'opération sera en difficulté
nous avons besoin de comprendre et de
savoir l'état de la situation et l'état
de discussion avec les dirigeants des
Comores
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
monsieur le Président du fait madame la
ministre de faire étrangère aurait pu
largement répondre à cette question mais
bien sûr vous rassurer sur le fait que
nous avons avec les Comores une
coopération efficace depuis 4 ans
puisque chaque année je prends l'exemple
de l'année dernière 25000 reconduites à
la frontière dont 100% des personnes
comoriennes qui ont été condamnées par
la justice française ont été renvoyés
aux Comores à vous et vous qui
connaissez très bien ces questions que
ces résultats on aimerait les avoir avec
d'autres pays donc nous avons avec les
Comores évidemment une bonne coopération
dans la circonstance dans lequel nous
sommes rappelés d'ailleurs par le
sénateur du groupe communiste il vient
de revendication vous le savez
historique des Comores à récupérer je
mets évidemment des guillemets l'île de
Mayotte et dans les circonstances
dequelles nous sommes aujourd'hui je
pense bien évidemment aux circonstances
électorales qui touchent la partie
comorienne nous avons des discussions
qui pour l'instant font que il n'y a
plus d'échanges pas simplement entre
étrangers en situation irrégulière et
s'est passé consulaire mais entre
personnes qui viennent de Mayotte pour
aller vers les Comores et des Comores
pour les var-maillottes et si j'étais
encore plus précis dans jouant surtout
pour venir à Mayotte qui n'a pas
toujours vous le savez bien la même
position que Moroni et donc aujourd'hui
depuis 5 jours il n'y a plus d'échange
de bateau officiellement pour des
raisons techniques au port d'Anjouan
entre Mayotte et les Comores qui
s'agissent des étrangers sociaux
régulières ou qu'il s'agisse de simples
voyageurs tout à fait régulier des deux
côtés de la frontière et de la mer nous
utilisons tous les moyens diplomatiques
pour renouveler le contact j'ai eu
moi-même trois fois cette semaine le
ministre de l'Intérieur je l'ai
d'ailleurs invité à venir me rejoindre à
Paris il a accepté cette habitation dans
quelques heures dans quelques jours je
le recevrai pour reprendre la
coopération avec les Comores si nous
continuons les 25000 reconduites à la
frontière chaque année nous arriverons à
tenir notre objectif de lutte
contremigration irrégulière à Mayotte
puisque vous savez que le problème
particulier n'est pas tellement la
reconduite à Mayotte mais l'arrivée des
fois ça quoi ça et je veux ici constater
que la mobilisation de la étrangère la
mobilisation des policiers des gendarmes
en nombre il y a 1500 policiers
gendarmes à Mayotte en ce moment faut
qu'il y a quasiment pas d'arriver de
quoi ça quoi ça et donc si nous
reprenons les reconduites classiques en
lien avec nos amis des Comores tout en
empêchant l'arrivée de quoi ça quoi ça
nous aurons limité fortement
l'immigration irrégulière à Mayotte j'en
précise pour dire qu'il faut aussi
changer le droit à Mayotte on est
l'occasion de faire des propositions
nous en parlerons peut-être dans un
texte immigration nous discuterons
bientôt nous l'espérons tous monsieur le
président de la commission des lois mais
aussi dans le débat constitutionnel que
nous pourrions avoir demain ou
après-demain allemand du président de la
République j'ai déjà dit que j'étais
favorable à modification du droit du sol
à Mayotte pour limiter notamment cet
appel d'air sur le territoire mahorais
sur le président buffet
avec impatience le texte immigration
pour essayer d'apporter effectivement
une réponse nous l'attendons et comme ce
Rane pour l'instant nous ne voyons rien
venir mais peut-être que cela viendra et
en tous les cas nous y passerons le
temps qu'il faut cependant c'est vrai
qu'il ait été utile que nous l'ayons car
je pense qu'il reste si convaincu qu'il
faut maintenir dans le texte l'idée
qu'il ne peut pas y avoir de visa s'il
n'y a pas de laisser passer consulaire
et tant qu'on n'apportera pas un rapport
en mettra pas en place un rapport de
force puissant avec les pays sources
nous aurons beaucoup de mal et la
situation risquera de se continuer tel
qu'elle est aujourd'hui mais je crois
que pour Mayotte la solution n'est pas
seulement celle-ci elle est évidemment
substantielle mais il faut donner un
avenir à Mayotte lui donner un projet un
projet économique et un investissement
de long terme qui seul sera à terme le
garant d'une vie normale de nos
concitoyens Mahorais merci
[Musique]
la parole notre collègue Stéphane
Demilly pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie cela
a été dit vendredi dernier l'agence de
notation Fitch a dégradé la note de
crédit de la France la faisant passer de
double a à double a moins pour justifier
sa décision l'agence évoque notamment je
cite des déficits budgétaires importants
et des progrès modestes concernant la
réduction des déséquilibres cela après
trois ans d'abondance dépenses publiques
destinées à amortir le choc du covid et
de l'inflation
comme les deux autres agences de
notation très connues SNP et moodies la
principale activité de Fitch consiste à
évaluer la capacité des États à
rembourser leur dette en leur attribuant
une note matérialisée par des lettres la
meilleure note est triple A pour
signifier un crédit de qualité optimale
ce que nous avions d'ailleurs avant 2012
la pire est C ou D où on se rapproche du
défaut de paiement
la note de la France a donc été dégradée
d'un cran vendredi dernier cette
décision comme la constatait le FCE va à
contre-courant du signal envoyé au
marché par le gouvernement avec
l'adoption de la réforme des retraites
une réforme censée attester d'une
volonté de maîtrise des équilibres
budgétaires à long terme mais avec cette
note la réalité est aujourd'hui tout
autre s'il y a une perte de crédibilité
de notre pays sur sa capacité à
rembourser sa dette nous serons
hypothétiquement amenés à emprunter plus
cher sur les marchés donc à payer plus
d'intérêt cela grivera les finances
publiques et nos marges de manœuvres
budgétaires qui sont nous le savons tous
déjà très contraintes rappelons que la
chair de la dette publique est passée en
quelques mois de 37 à 50 milliards
d'euros
alors concrètement monsieur le ministre
quelle mesure comptez-vous prendre pour
que nous retrouvions sur les places
financières internationales un label de
confiance et de crédibilité rassurant
pour nos prêteurs et pour le dire
autrement monsieur le ministre comment
comptez-vous enrayer ces dégradations de
la notation de la France pour vous
répondre la parole est au ministre de
l'économie et les finances Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
sénateurs monsieur sénateur de Billy je
connais votre attachement à la bonne
tenue des comptes publics et je sais
pouvoir compter sur vous pour adopter
dans quelque semaines à la loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
nous permettra de donner le cadre de ce
rétablissement première remarque la
France n'a pas de difficultés à lever de
la dette sur les marchés deux agences se
sont prononcés il y a eu une dégradation
de Fitch nous disent en revanche je le
rappelle la page jugé bon de modifier la
notation de la France et nous attendons
la troisième décision qui sera celle de
l'agence Standard d'un pur's au début du
mois de juin je constate également que
sur les marchés vous m'interrogez sur la
précision des chiffres le spread avec
l'Allemagne a peu évolué de 50 à 59
points de base preuve qu'il y a une
véritable solidité de la France parce
qu'elle émet de la dette sur les marchés
je rappelle que pour l'Italie ce spread
est de l'ordre de plus de 180 points de
base donc gardons notre sang-froid sur
la crédibilité de la dette française et
de la signature française ensuite je
vous rejoins à 1000% bien sûr que nous
devons avoir une stratégie cohérente
stable déterminée de rétablissement des
finances publiques elle passe tout de
suite par trois décisions immédiates la
revue des dépenses publiques qui a été
engagée par la première ministre et qui
aura lieu je tiens le dire par l'année
2023 mais toutes les années à partir de
l'année 2023 ce qui veut dire que
chacune des dépenses publiques sera
examinée pour vérifier que véritablement
elle remplit le service que nos
compatriotes sont en droit d'attendre
deuxième rendez-vous les assises des
finances publiques pour nous engager sur
la trajectoire que j'ai indiquée
troisième rendez-vous la loi de
programmation des finances publiques qui
gravera dans le marbre la trajectoire
financière de la France et
l'accélération du désendettement qui est
marqué dans le programme de stabilité
quatre points de désendettement
supérieur à ce que nous avions envisagé
moi j'aimerais simplement que tous ceux
qui ici croient dans la nécessité
d'avoir des finances publiques bien
tenues nous rejoignent dans cette
détermination à accélérer le
désendettement de la France
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant
à Jean-François Husson rapporteur
général pour le groupe les républicain
monsieur le ministre des Finances dans
une France en proie malheureusement à
des tensions sociales persistantes la
récente dégradation de la note de la
France a double a négatif par une agence
de notation confirme s'il en était
besoin nous inquiétudes au regard de
l'incapacité à réduire notre endettement
qui atteint des sommets on pourrait bien
sûr espérer bénéficier d'une croissance
soutenue mais les prévisions fournies
par les économistes pour la période 2023
2027 sont bien moins favorables que
celle du gouvernement cela aura donc
nécessairement des effets sur
l'évolution des recettes publiques et
par suite sur les déficits pouvez-vous
monsieur le ministre confirmé que ce
camouflet financier à tout le moins
c'est alerte adressée au gouvernement ne
vous
ne vous inspire pas d'inquiétude
particulière et que nos comptes publics
ne dérivent pas dangereusement quelles
conséquences enfin en tirez-vous sur
l'évolution des conditions de
financement de la France et sur
l'évolution de la charge de la dette
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'économie et des finances
sur le maire
oui monsieur le sénateur Husson là aussi
je connais votre engagement sur le sujet
des sciences physiques je suis pas là
pour être inquiet je suis là pour être
déterminé
et déterminer dans le rétablissement des
finances publiques avec des décisions
très structurantes qui d'ailleurs ont
été votées pour certaines par votre
groupe dont je salue l'esprit de
responsabilité les premières décisions
structurantes ça a été la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et la réforme des
retraites que vous avez votées et dont
je rappelle que fiche contrairement à ce
que j'entends dire trop souvent à saluer
l'efficacité pour le rétablissement des
finances publiques la deuxième décision
très concrète ça va être la sortie du
bouclier tarifaire la fin du gel sur les
prix du gaz puisque les prix du gaz sont
revenus à la normale et la sortie
progressive du plafonnement sur les prix
de l'électricité nous voulons que d'ici
la fin 2024 début 2025 soyons sortis
définitivement et totalement des
boucliers tarifaires qui étaient utiles
pour protéger nos compatriotes quand
c'était nécessaire mais qui ne sont plus
utiles dès lors que les prix reviennent
à la baisse j'espère que vous nous
soutiendrez aussi dans cette décision
enfin troisième remarque la loi de
programmation des finances publiques une
fois encore j'en ai parlé à plusieurs
reprises avec le président de votre
groupe je reste ouvert à tout
amélioration qui permettra d'adopter
cette loi de programmation des finances
publiques et de graver dans le marbre
cet engagement pourquoi c'est important
mais pas pour faire plaisir aux agences
de notation mais une fois encore pour
rétablir totalement et pleinement notre
indépendance et notre souveraineté
financière et tout simplement aussi
parce qu'en période d'augmentation des
taux d'intérêt laisser filer la dette
comme le propose certains c'est jeter
l'argent par les fenêtres un point de
taux d'intérêt supplémentaire c'est
horizon 2027 15 milliards d'euros de
charges supplémentaires sur la charge de
la dette c'est plus que le budget du
garde des sceaux je pense que le Garde
des Sceaux est surtout tous nos
compatriotes préfèrent qu'on dépense de
l'argent pour les policiers pour la
sécurité pour les gendarmes pour la
justice pour l'école pour l'hôpital pour
les services publics plutôt que pour le
service de la dette c'est pour cela que
vous pouvez compter monsieur le sénateur
sur ma détermination totale à rétablir
les finances publiques et accélérer nos
endettement
monsieur rapporteur général
oui vous dites monsieur le ministre
déterminé si j'en juge par les six
années qui sont passées et le résultat
qui est celui qu'on constate aujourd'hui
au moins je fais un constat c'est que
vous avez singulièrement manqué des
dominations deuxième élément qui me
paraît inquiétant puisque je suis
également inquiet ce sont les chiffres
qui sont dans le programme de stabilité
que nous allons examiner ce soir que
nous avons mis à Bruxelles où je dois
vous dire que les dépenses par rapport à
la loi de programmation que nous avons
étudié à la fin de l'année en décembre
elles ont augmenté de 30 milliards
d'euros dérives supplémentaires alors
Monsieur le Ministre oui nous sommes
déterminés mais nous sommes déterminés
pour un temps de vérité et non pas pour
du camouflage parce que ce qui est en
train de se passer vous nous demandez de
travailler sur la loi de programmation
des finances publiques mais alors
pourquoi avez-vous continué à dépenser
de l'argent que nous n'avons pas qu'il
faut aller emprunter quand nous vous
avons proposé au mois de décembre des
pistes d'économie vous avez balayé d'un
revers de main ces regrettable donc je
vais vous dire comme je l'ai dit il y a
pas très longtemps monsieur le ministre
il faut vraiment se mettre au travail
la parole est à notre collègue Nicole
Bonnefoy pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains merci
monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues on ne compte plus les
fermetures temporaires de service
d'urgence ou hospitalier aux quatre
coins du pays le Sénat par sa
connaissance du côté D1 de nos
compatriotes vous interpelle depuis des
mois
même dire depuis des années sur l'un des
certifications médicales à l'oeuvre qui
se déporte à présent vers l'hôpital et
les urgences je vous questionnais
moi-même encore récemment sur le risque
de fermeture de l'hôpital de Ruffec ou
de Confolens dans mon département en
Charente c'est ainsi en cascade
qu'arrive les nouvelles fermetures de
services que par euphémisme vous appelez
suspension temporaire pas un territoire
bien souvent rural n'était pas nié par
l'avalanche de défections de médecins
épuisée par la charge de travail de nuit
comme de jour les maternités ferment en
pagaille par manque un médecin et
mettent en danger la vie des femmes
monsieur le ministre je vous prie
d'écouter les territoires attention à ne
pas considérer un service fermé comme un
service désengorgé à ce stade la
promesse d'Emmanuel Macron d'améliorer
l'offre de soins d'ici la fin de l'année
est un mirage vous devez ce mercredi
faire un premier bilan du CNR santé nous
avons eu ce matin un aperçu peut
convaincant sur France Inter de votre
boîte à outils la situation n'est pas
acceptable vous le savez et les Français
comme les élus locaux ont besoin de
clarté sur les données du ministère en
matière de fermeture le recours massif
au 15 est-il l'alpha et l'oméga de vos
moyens d'action l'urgence des urgences
monsieur le ministre c'est l'accès à la
santé et non les retraites où sont vos
propositions de régulation de l'accès
aux soins où est votre vision de moyen
terme pour assurer la continuité du
service public de santé
pour vous répondre la parole est obligé
de la santé de la prévention monsieur
Braun
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Bonnefoy
ce qui serait surtout un mirage c'est de
vouloir faire croire aux Français que
nous pourrons demain avoir 5000 ou 10000
médecins de plus ce n'est pas vrai il
faut le dire et c'est bien notre
organisation globale qui doit être
repensée alors dans ce cette
réorganisation nous sommes en train nous
tous ensemble de gagner le combat contre
les dérives de l'intérim médical je dis
nous parce que c'est le gouvernement
sous l'autorité de la première ministre
les professionnels de santé et les élus
territoire par territoire qui nous
permettent de gagner ce combat
indispensable pour la survie de notre
hôpital public cette dérive de l'intérim
médical amenaient la fuite des médecins
hospitaliers de l'hôpital public alors
quels ont été les solutions mises en
place et y compris dans votre
département de Charente et pour
l'hôpital de Confolens qui assure
réouvrir entre guillemets son service
des urgences et bien c'est la solidarité
territoriale qui est portée par les ARS
c'est la possibilité de travailler de
façon plus intelligente à l'échelle d'un
territoire pour que les parcours de
soins ne soient pas interrompu ne soit
pas rompu et qu'on continue à garantir
la sécurité la qualité des soins pour
nous tous nos concitoyens d'une façon
plus structurelle et pour répondre à
l'engagement du président de la
République sur les services d'urgence
bien entendu un service d'urgence fermé
n'est pas un service d'urgence
désengorgé ça semble une évidence mais
par contre nous avons les outils pour
aboutir à se désengorgement ça passe
d'abord par une meilleure gestion de la
Manche doit rappeler que le sas dont
vous parlez qui est une des solutions
c'est la première fois que l'été dernier
grâce à la mise en application du numéro
15 et en demandant à nos concitoyens
adaptés SAMU que nous avons pu faire
diminuer la fréquentation de nos
services d'urgence et cela perdure dans
les départements qui ont mis en place ça
s'il a également d'autres solutions
l'aval des urgences la gestion des leads
a aussi à l'échelle territoriale avec le
public et avec le privé et puis enfin
quelques éléments de réorganisation de
nos services pour qu'ils soient plus
fluide donc vous le voyez ce mirage
comme vous dites n'est loin d'être
inatteignables et là aussi nous
l'intiendrons territoire par territoire
et tous ensemble je vous remercie
[Musique]
oui j'ai le regret de vous dire Monsieur
le Ministre que avec le gouvernement
vous gérez la crise de l'hôpital à la
petite semaine sans vision d'ensemble
sans mesurer les conséquences de vos
propres lois comme celle sur l'intérim
vous éradiquer la médecine de proximité
et vous condamnez des territoires
entiers à la rupture de soins
Dominique Estrosi ça sonne pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
conscience s'adresse à madame la
Première ministre les titres de Prince
sont multipliés ces derniers jours pour
parler de bombes sociales de
catastrophes des voix de plus en plus
nombreuses s'élèvent pour alerter sur
les dangers de cette crise du logement
qui cause une fatigue quotidienne pour
tous les personnes qui sont obligées
d'habiter loin de leur lieu de travail
qui créent une angoisse pour toutes
celles qui arrivent à la fin de leur vie
active sans possibilité d'acheter un
toit qui provoque la colère de ceux qui
savent qu'ils ne peuvent pas habiter
dans leur région près de leur famille
victime de prix dissuasifs cent mille
mal logés de plus 10% de personnes à la
rue de plus 100000 demandeurs de
logement sociaux de plus que l'année
dernière
os des taux d'intérêt construction neuve
en berne gigantesque chantier de la
rénovation énergétique marché de la
location grippée parcours résidentiel
bloqué tous les voyants sont au rouge et
votre gouvernement puisqu'il y a peu
encore était dans un déni total voire
pire encore aux abonnés absents alors
madame la Première ministre pourquoi
avoir autant négligé la politique du
logement qui est au cœur de la vie
quotidienne de tous les Français
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé de la ville et
du Logement monsieur Klein merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice Dominique Estrosi ça sonne
évidemment que le logement est une
priorité de ce gouvernement et nous y
travaillons depuis de nombreux mois et
c'est une priorité du président de la
République depuis 2017 le plan le plan
logement d'abord qui a permis à 440 000
familles de quitter la rue pour obtenir
à toi est un plan qui a fonctionné le
lancement de ma prime rénov malgré les
difficultés que je n'ai pas est un plan
qui fonctionne plus d'un million cinq de
chantier ont été réussis oui il y a une
crise aujourd'hui du logement nous
n'avons pas découvert au détour
d'articles de presse nous y travaillons
depuis plusieurs mois et le mot bombe
social est un mot que j'ai employé
moi-même dès le mois de novembre dernier
parce que cette crise où nous la
pressentions elle n'est pas le fait du
précédent gouvernement il est fait d'une
politique de logement insuffisant depuis
de nombreuses années et nous allons y
répondre nous allons y répondre comme
madame la Première ministre l'a dit dans
sa feuille de route avec un certain
nombre d'initiatives immédiates une
action avec la Caisse des Dépôts comme
elle avait déjà été menée à la fin de la
crise covid d'acquisition de logements
pour sortir un certain nombre de projets
qui sont aujourd'hui bloqués le note
priorité c'est de loger tous les
Français de manière digne et abordable
donc aider aider la promotion
immobilière c'est de toute la filière de
la de l'habitat à la fois l'habitat
privé mais aussi l'habitat social et
nous le ferons nous travaillons avec le
ministre
de l'économie et des finances avec les
banques pour faciliter l'accès au crédit
car vous le savez aujourd'hui avec
l'augmentation des taux l'accès au
crédit est difficile et avec Bruno Le
Maire nous y travaillons et Christophe
Vichy nous y travaillons d'arrache-pied
enfin comme la première ministre l'a
annoncé nous travaillons au maintien du
PTZ qui a un moyen pour nos concitoyens
d'accéder au logement d'avoir une
possibilité d'avoir un apport personnel
puisque le PTZ est souvent considéré de
la sorte et je peux vous assurer et vous
y êtes invité lors du Conseil national
de refondation du logement qui sera
présenté le 9 mai nous continuerons à
travailler tous ensemble à l'union
sacrée du logement je vous remercie
madame Estrosi
la première ministre effectivement je
pense que vous avez dressé une fois de
plus en constat aborder avec quelques
mesures conjoncturelles dans la feuille
de route des 100 jours de madame la
Première ministre on parle simplement de
facilité l'accès au logement et de
favoriser le mieux vivre mais on a
besoin au-delà des réformes et de
problèmes conjoncturels d'apporter des
remèdes à des problèmes structurels il
faut une véritable remise à plat de la
politique du logement ainsi qu'un
inventaire de la réglementation c'est du
bon sens mais aussi de l'urgence parce
que sinon cette crise du logement
derrière elle se profile une crise
sociale une crise sociétale hautement
inflam mable dans un pays qui est déjà à
fleur de peau
la parole de taux président
Jean-François Longeot pour le groupe de
l'Union centrif vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
mais la question à laquelle j'asselis
j'associe mon excellent collègue
Philippe Tabaro s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre des Transports
monsieur le ministre le Conseil
d'orientation des infrastructures a
remis son rapport à la première ministre
il y a plus de deux mois les principales
annonces du gouvernement sont conformes
à ce que la commission d'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
préconisé un effort massif sur le
ferroviaire 100 milliards d'euros à
l'horizon 2040 dont la moitié sur le
réseau le lancement des CPR très attendu
par les élus et un mandat donné à la
Société du Grand Paris pour instruire
les projets de RER métropolitain
l'annonce de ce plan suscite néanmoins
plusieurs interrogations la régénération
du réseau est effectivement
urgente l'âge moyen de ce dernier est de
30 ans en France contre 17 chez nos
voisins allemands il nous faudra donc
dans les prochaines années stabiliser
l'âge moyen de ce dernier avant de le
faire redescendre via une augmentation
des opérations de régénération
la décourbonation des transports
nécessitera un report modal massif de
véhicules individuel vers le train la
stratégie annoncée par le président de
la République de développer des réseaux
de RER métropolitain et la bonne ces
derniers permettront à l'échelle du pays
de supprimer des millions de trajet en
voiture et d'offrir aux habitants des
grandes métropoles des réseaux de
transport en commun performant qui ne
seront plus la panache de la seule
région parisienne à titre personnel je
me réjouis du mandat donné à la Société
du Grand Paris d'instruire les projets
de RER métropolitain en combinant son
expertise avec celle de la SNCF réseau
je crois que la France à tous les atouts
permettant de mener à bien cette grande
entreprise
monsieur le ministre pourriez-vous
préciser la position du Gouvernement sur
ce texte et partager à la représentation
nationale des projets du gouvernement en
matière de RER des développements de
ceci plus largement je souhaite vous
interroger monsieur le ministre sur les
modalités de financement du coi ma
question est simple quels sont les
méthodes de financement envisagées par
le gouvernement je vous remercie
pour vos réponses déléguer chargez les
transports
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
Président lonjo le 10 mars dernier la
première ministre a en effet présenté un
ambitieux plan d'avenir pour les
transports qui doit beaucoup aux travaux
et aux priorités de votre commission et
aux travaux qu'apportaient au sein du
Conseil orientation de l'infrastructures
notamment votre excellent collègue
Philippe Tabaro en effet nous aurons
l'occasion de discuter le ces budgets
quelques orientations en réponse aux
questions que vous soulignez d'abord la
priorité que nous partageons que j'ai
indiqué dans cette hémicycle à plusieurs
reprises au réseau ferroviaire nous
avons un effet malgré des
réinvestissements récents réseaux
ferroviaire bien plus bien plus vieux
que le réseau ferroviaire de nos voisins
allemands et nos principaux voisins
européens nous allons la première
ministre l'a indiqué augmenter
progressivement d'ici la fin de
législature le 50% cela n'a jamais été
fait de 50% les crédits annuels investis
dans le réseau ferroviaire français
c'est la condition pour restaurer un
certain nombre de lignes parfois
sinistrées délaissés qui traversent
notre territoire Bordeaux Marseille
Paris Limoges Paris dont vous connaissez
la vétusté la nécessité du
réinvestissement c'est aussi une
priorité donnée au service express
métropolitain qui je le rappelle ne sont
pas des projets au service des
centres-villes mais des projets qui
visent à développer une alternative à la
voiture individuelle dans les
périphéries à 30 40 50 80 km des
centres-villes et la proposition de loi
présentait à l'Assemblée nationale par
le président Voulzy pour être très clair
nous la soutiendrons nous la
soutiendrons parce qu'elles mettent en
œuvre l'outil juridique notamment par
l'évolution du statut de la Société du
Grand Paris qui permettra de créer pour
les collectivités qui le souhaitent les
sociétés de projets qui porteront la
mise en oeuvre de ces projets il faut
financer en effet cet effort important
c'est 100 milliards d'euros
collectivement avec les collectivités
locales nous aurons dans le cadre de la
loi de programmation des finances
publiques des crédits qui se déploieront
les années qui suivent et il faudra
aussi mettre à contribution la première
ministre indiquée d'autres secteurs et
d'autres modes de transport le secteur
des routes les sociétés autoroutières en
particulier le secteur aérien nous le
ferons en débattant ici même lors des
prochains budgets et puis je veux
inciter sur un projet qui tient à cœur
au Sénat en particulier c'est la
question du lion Turin nous avons bien
sûr cette priorité à cœur j'aurai
l'occasion d'échanger avec le point de
régions Auvergne Rhône-Alpes dans
quelques jours parce que nous devons
porter cet effort budgétaire
collectivement l'état s'y engage mais
nous aurons besoin d'être soutenu et
accompagné je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
mouiller pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
j'ai participé la semaine dernière à la
Conférence nationale du handicap réunion
à laquelle d'ailleurs j'en présentais
notre président du Sénat cette 6e
édition de la CNH s'est tenue dans des
circonstances particulières alors que
ces conférences ont été jusqu'à présent
des moments de partage d'objectifs avec
les acteurs du monde du handicap cela
n'a pas été le cas cette année après de
la fait connaître leur insatisfaction en
amont et demander un report de plusieurs
semaines en fin d'engager un virage
véritable travail de concertation de
nombreuses associations dont le
collectif handicap non pas participé à
cette CNH cette situation est
dommageable d'autant qu'un consensus
peut être trouvé au regard des
thématiques de travail retenu
au cours de cette CNH le prendre la
République a énumérer un certain nombre
de propositions concernant
l'accessibilité la scolarisation
l'emploi l'accès aux soins et nous ne
pouvons que saluer un certain nombre de
mesures je pense notamment aux 1,5
milliards d'euros annoncé pour
l'accessibilité le remboursement à 100%
des fauteuils roulants ou la création de
50000 solutions en établissement et dans
les services sur cinq ans mais en
écoutant le discours de prendre la
République les 70 engagements et
nombreuses mesures afférentes nous nous
posons tous cette question comment
financer ce programme qui se chiffre à
plus de 4 milliards d'euros je remercie
pour votre réponse
pour vous répondre la parole de la
ministre déléguée chargée des personnes
handicapées vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur le sénateur Moulié
d'abord je vous remercie pour cette
question qui permet de mettre le focus
sur cette conférence nationale du
handicap qui était un moment important
pour le monde du handicap pour les
personnes handicapées pour les
associations pour les familles qui
étaient un moment attendu vous l'avez
dit ou certaines associations ont grincé
un petit peu des dents sans que je
comprenne véritablement quel était le
sujet parce que la préparation de cette
conférence nationale du handicap ça a
été huit groupes de travail 40 réunions
500 personnes mobilisées beaucoup de
contributions écrites que nous avons
intégré à la réflexion en fait c'est une
vraie co-construction qui a été réalisée
avec des comités de pilotage également
qui ont donné les conclusions au fur et
à mesure de l'évolution des travaux donc
cette mauvaise humeur moi je la prends
pour ce qu'elle est je constate quand
même que la MAJ mettez des associations
de ce collectif handicap étaient
présentes lors de cette CNH et je crois
que les associations sont exigeantes et
qu'elles ont raison d'être exigeantes
parce que elle souhaite simplement que
les handicapés et les personnes
handicapées acceptent pleinement à leurs
droits et accéder pleinement à leurs
droits notamment par exemple sur les
sujets d'accessibilité dont vous avez
parlé l'engagement du président de la
République c'est un milliard 5 sur
l'accessibilité des fonds pour les
collectivités afin qu'elles accélèrent
leur programme d'accessibilité et des
fonds pour les petits propriétaires pour
les propriétaires pardon de petits ERP
les commerces du quotidien et les
cabinets médicaux par exemple afin
qu'ils accélèrent cette cette mise en
accessibilité et bien nous sommes très
en retard et je crois que cette
déclaration cette volonté de mettre
notre pays en marche vers une
accessibilité totale et bien fera
plaisir aux associations et fera en
sorte bien qu'elle reviendront toujours
dans la co-construction que nous avons
réalisé pour cette CNH et je n'ai pas le
temps de répondre à votre question mais
un investissement pluriannuel et prévu
et bien sûr tout cela sera mis à
disposition du Sénat et à votre
disposition quand tous les tableaux
d'investissement pluriel seront établies
monsieur mouillé madame la ministre
merci pour votre réponse qui est
forcément incomplète tout d'abord
concernant la méthode ça nous rappelle
un peu la méthode de ce gouvernement
faire participer les associations et des
rayons de travail ce n'est pas forcément
validé le projet du gouvernement et donc
il y a une nuance qui est importante
concernant le financement les sommes
sont élevées vous avez dit l'objectif
est aussi un évite élevé mais ici où ça
nous serons vigilants sur deux choses
d'abord au moment du PLF et du PLFSS
2024 nous serons vigilants pour voir la
traduction des engagements du présent de
la République dans les comptes qui ne
seront proposés mais surtout nous serons
vigilants qu'il n'y ait pas de transfert
de charges sur des collectivités car le
principe à la fois de l'utilisation de
la deta d'être de la des cils doivent
pas être transférés sur le front de
visibilité et les départements également
ont également une vigilance sur les
politiques médico-sociales le grand
principe quand l'État s'engage les
tailles paix merci
la parole de notre collègue Jean-Jacques
Rousseau pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président madame la ministre
vous le savez la précarité énergétique
est bien réelle et les subies
quotidiennement par un nombre croissant
de nos concitoyens dans ce contexte plus
de 2 millions de personnes seront
effectivement affectés par l'extinction
des tarifs réglementés du gaz prévu le
30 juin et en vérité plus de 7 millions
de ménages si on tient compte de ceux
qui ont basculé en offre de marche et
dans les contrats sont indexés sur le
tarif réglementé certes vous avez
annoncé la prolongation du bouclier
tarifaire jusqu'à la fin de l'année mais
si la volatilité à la hausse des prix
énergétiques demeure face aux
dysfonctionnement du marché de l'énergie
la perte de la maîtrise publique
tarifaire garantie par des tarifs
réglementés auxquels se raccroche le
boulier tarifaire est évidente
qu'adviendra-t-il alors pour les
consommateurs en 2024 il y a là une
grande inconnue et êtes-vous en mesure
d'assurer que le basculement sur l'offre
passerait ou d'autres contrats n'est pas
d'incidence sur les tarifs à court moyen
terme car de toute évidence piste évoqué
par le gouvernement visant à mettre en
place un prix de référence déterminé par
le Commission de régulation de l'énergie
qui servirait de base à la poursuite du
bouclier tarifaire n'offre aucune
garantie sûrement passée de tarifs
réglementé qui était fixé par les
pouvoirs publics on le voit bien le
débat n'est pas nouveau il ressurgit
aujourd'hui quelle est notre capacité à
retrouver une maîtrise publique
tarifaire sur les biens de première
nécessité que sont l'électricité ou le
gaz alors madame la ministre voici ma
question alors que l'inflation et les
dérèglements du marché sont toujours en
action entendez-vous reporter la fin des
tarifs réglementés et plus largement
au-delà des dispositifs conjoncturels
par ailleurs bienvenue quels sont les
mesures que le Gouvernement prend au
sein de l'Union européenne pour que le
prix du gaz est en conséquence de
l'électricité n'atteignent pas des
niveaux exorbitants sans commune quand
sans commune mesure avec les coûts de
production de l'électricité dans notre
pays
pour répondre la parole l'état la
ministre de la transition énergétique
madame panier une hache
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Michaud merci pour cette
question qui va me permettre de rassurer
ceux qui nous écoutent tout d'abord et
je pense que c'est important de le
préciser et peut-être contrairement à ce
que vous laissez entendre le tarif
règlementé du gaz est un tarif de marché
c'est un tarif qui évolue chaque mois
sur la base d'une formule et qui a
augmenté de 200 % entre octobre 2021 et
octobre 2022 et vous l'avez bien compris
c'est pas ça qui protège les Français
vous l'avez d'ailleurs mentionné ce qui
protège les Français c'est le bouclier
énergétique quand les prix du gaz se
sont affolés comme l'année dernière et
le ministre de l'Économie le disait un
instant ses tarifs de ce prix du gaz est
désormais rentrer grossièrement dans
l'ordre
ce bouclier il sera prolongé jusqu'à la
fin de l'année il concerne tous les
ménages qui se chauffent et qui cuisine
au gaz qu'il soit au TR Vegas ou pas
alors qu'est-ce que change cette
évolution du TRV gaz vous savez que
c'est une décision de justice qui a tenu
à supprimer cette référence et donc nous
accompagnons les Français et au fond ça
va pas changer grand chose pour les
Français les 2 millions de Français qui
aujourd'hui ont un contrat sur la base
du TER Vegas pourquoi soit ils font le
choix de conclure un contrat avec un
fournisseur de gaz qui leur convient
soit il ne faut rien et automatiquement
il bénéficieront de leur fournisseurs de
gaz un contrat qui sera effectivement
sur la base d'un tarif qui est calculé
par la creux c'est au fond exactement la
même chose que par le passé sauf que au
lieu d'imposer à engie de suivre ce
tarif
à suivre ce tarif il n'y aura évidemment
aucun coût de changement de contrat
aucun changement de compteur cela se
fait automatiquement et je veux dire ici
je crois que la première ministre la
répéter à de nombreuses reprises aucun
pays n'a comme ce gouvernement autant
protéger les Français contre l'évolution
des coûts de l'électricité et du gaz et
vous pouvez compter sur nous pour
continuer à accompagner les Français
dans ces tensions la parole est à notre
collègue Muriel Jourdain pour le groupe
les républicains
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues bah question est pour monsieur
le ministre de l'Intérieur et je voulais
à mon tour évoqué les violences d'une
brutalité inouïe dont les forces de
l'ordre on fait l'objet lors des
manifestations du 1er mai dernier chacun
je crois à garder en tête l'image de ce
policier en feu qui
je l'espère je le pense à ému et
horrifié la quasi-totalité des Français
et il s'agissait d'un policier parmi les
plus de 400 membres des forces de
l'ordre qui ont été blessés à cette
occasion et vers lesquels vont tout nos
vœux de rétablissement à cette occasion
monsieur le ministre vous avez déclaré
que ces violences étaient inacceptables
vous l'avez déclaré le jour même vous la
déclaré le lendemain lors de questions
gouvernement à l'Assemblée nationale
vous l'aviez dans des conditions
similaires déclarées le 25 mars 2023 à
Sainte-Soline le 23 mars 2023 Lorient le
29 octobre 2022 dans les Deux-Sèvres le
1er mai 2022 déjà à Paris le 14 avril
2022 à Rennes le 20 mars 2021 Verdun
j'arrête là parce que je ne pourrais pas
remonter jusqu'à la date de votre entrée
en fonction qui était au mois de juillet
2020 je n'en ai pas le temps ces
violences sont inacceptables nous en
sommes d'accord et nous pouvons être à
vos côtés pour vous le dire
et après que faisons-nous ou plutôt que
faites-vous
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'intérieur des Outre-mer
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice merci de soutenir les
policiers légendes j'applique la loi de
la République madame la sénatrice ser la
loi votée par deux chambres et
d'ailleurs je suis tout à fait dans le
regret de vous dire que le gouvernement
est à l'écoute de la proposition de
Monsieur retaillou qui a été adopté par
la haute comme la basse assemblée et
pour autant cela a été censuré par le
Conseil constitutionnel si vous attendez
du ministre de l'Intérieur qui loot
repasse les lois de la République pour
appliquer sa loi personnelle nous
serions pas en démocratie donc la
question que je vous pose madame la
sénatrice la question que je veux vous
savez c'est que proposez-vous le
gouvernement a fait des propositions
le gouvernement a fait des propositions
même après mise ça a répété à une
question de monsieur le Président maluré
le garde des sceaux l'a dit ce matin à
une chaîne de grande écoute nous sommes
favorables à remettre l'ouvrage sur le
métier d'une proposition de loi d'un
projet de loi qu'importe le père du
moment qui le porte des beaux enfants
franchement madame la satrice pour que
nous lutions contre ces casseurs qui non
seulement attaque évoluer des policiers
des gendarmes mais empêche les
manifestants de manifester je vous
renvoie d'ailleurs à ce titre et je dis
pour le groupe du Parti communiste que
je salue ici au communiqué du Parti
communiste français qui évoquait que des
Black Blocs ont agressé des élus et des
membres du parti communiste et je me
réjouis que le Parti communiste comme la
plupart des grands partis républicains
soit sur la même position que vous on
peut donc se retrouver pour que nous
puissions avoir l'équivalent de ce que
nous avons dans les stades de football
que des hooligans n'aillent plus dans
des stades pour aller voir des matchs de
football parce qu'on va pas voir un
match de football avec des cocktails
Molotov dans la poche on ne va pas dans
des manifestations avec des cocktails
Motors dans la poche et quand on est
très connu des services de police et
très violent le ministre d'intérieur est
comme vous il aimerait pouvoir leur
interdire à aller dans des
manifestations simplement la loi madame
la satrice vous l'aurez constaté et j'ai
pas le droit de la commission des lois
ne permet pas aux mises en intérieur
donc votons ensemble un texte qui
permettra d'être au rendez-vous de ce
rendez-vous
madame Jourdain
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre de
rappeler que effectivement le dernier
loi qui a voulu agir sur le sujet émaner
du groupe les républicains au Sénat et
peut-être n'aurait-elle pas été censurée
par le Conseil constitutionnel si nous
l'avions voté telle qu'elle et non pas
modifié par votre prédécesseur mais la
réalité c'est que je ne souhaite pas
polémiquer sur ces sujets je souhaite
juste que nous prenions ensemble la
mesure de l'enjeu qui est celui de ces
violences l'enjeu c'est l'état de droit
l'État de droit c'est la fin de la loi
du plus fort c'est une loi qui est votée
par le Parlement qui est appliquée par
une justice efficace et qui est
respectée parce que les forces de
l'ordre sont elles aussi respectées or
le Parlement il est mis à mal et sa
légitimité mise à mal pour toutes les
conventions citoyennes que vous décidez
la justice elle est considérée comme si
peu efficace par nos citoyens que les
exemples de justice privé se multiplient
dans le pays et les forces de l'ordre et
bien c'est le dernier pan qui si il va
elle va s'y et bien front vacille aussi
les doigts de droit l'État de droit
alors agissez
la parole est à notre collègue Nathalie
Goulet pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
oui monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs le ministre mes chers
collègues je voudrais d'abord à ce
moment précis assuré au nom de mon
groupe le soutien évidemment aux forces
de police de gendarmerie et aux forces
de maintien de la paix j'ai une question
pour le ministre de l'Intérieur qui
pourrait paraître anecdotique enfin
c'est peut-être un détail pour vous mais
peut nous pour nous ça veut dire
beaucoup il s'agit de les 40 pages de
circulaire pour l'élection des grands
électeurs aux élections au sénatoriales
en effet d'abord il faut saluer la date
du 9 juin qui est une date assez proche
d'habitude on avait les listes
électorales beaucoup plus tardivement
donc je vais d'abord vous remercier mais
en plus vous indiquez l'inquiétude d'un
certain nombre d'élus quant à la
complexité de cette circulaire notamment
en ce qui concerne les communes
nouvelles pour lesquelles il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'indications au plus
exactement trop d'indications pour que
ce soit vraiment clair sans que les
préfets puissent nous donner à l'heure
actuelle le nombre exact de grands
électeurs pour les communes nouvelles
comme je l'ai dit c'est peut-être un
détail pour vous mais pas pour les
sénateurs renouvelables par ailleurs la
date du 9 juin pose aussi un problème
car c'est une date fixe et il y a un
certain nombre d'élus qui ne pourront
pas être là ce jour-là et cette date est
pose pose problème car elle est aussi la
date du Congrès de la Fédération des
Centres de Gestion de la Fonction
Publique Territoriale qui se passe à
Ajaccio et qui va devoir évidemment
comprendre un certain nombre d'élus donc
monsieur le ministre je voulais vous
poser la question que pensez-vous faire
pour simplifier les dispositifs qui sont
actuellement en place
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
oui bonjour madame la sénatrice monsieur
le Président
de votre question parce que d'abord si
les lunes n'est pas là c'est pas vous
que je pense qu'il peut faire une
procuration malheureusement plus que les
élections centrales sont convoquées pour
le mois de septembre on n'a pas convoqué
les conseils municipaux en juillet et en
août qu'il semble que les sénateurs
aient envie de parler également aux
électeurs qui ne connaissent pas encore
c'est-à-dire se désigner par les
conseils municipaux que nous sommes au
mois de mai qui n'est pas de coutume de
le faire si tôt et qu'au mois de juin il
y a d'innombrables moments où les
Français ou les associations de luxe se
réunissent il y a des procurations
possibles on prévient je crois assez tôt
je crois qu'on a prévenu deux mois avant
la date pour l'ensemble des maires pour
convoquer ses conseils municipaux et il
est prévu d'ailleurs que si le Corum
n'est pas atteint parce que là nous
parlons bien des consignes municipaux
qui désignent des électeurs donc il
s'agit de quand même de ville en général
plutôt conséquente on va dire cela comme
ça en tout cas qui désigne des grands
électeurs
pas de Corum ils peuvent reconvoquer un
conseil municipal donc là franchement je
crois même assez triste que sur la
question de la date vous avez largement
la possibilité de convoquer ces conseils
municipaux sur la question des villes
nouvelles vous avez raison il y a une
multiplicité de vie nouvelle et
notamment des villes nouvelles qui sont
de taille de plus en plus importantes et
ces villes nouvelles refont faire le
calcul puisque ce n'est pas le cas dans
les précédentes élections sénatoriales
du nombre de grands électeurs chaque
préfet je suis étonné mais je me
renseigner dès cet après-midi auprès de
votre préfet de département s'il n'est
pas si vous l'expliquer on va donc
réexpliquer avec ce préfet département
mais j'imagine que peut-être il s'est
mal exprimé envers vous chaque préfet
connaît le nombre de grands électeurs
qui sont disponibles si j'ose dire dans
les villes qui désignent des gros
secteurs étant élus à Tourcoing je
connais déjà les grands électeurs que
mon conseiller municipal pourra désigner
pour la grande le grand plaisir des
sénateurs du Nord qui se présente au
suffrage des grands électeurs de
Tourcoing donc nous pouvons si vous le
souhaitez madame assezatrice
refaire Baster un message au préfet mais
je crois que ceux-ci désormais ont tous
les moyens pour pouvoir désigner les
grands électeurs pour qu'elles ont cette
règle se tiennent le mieux possible
madame Goulet
c'était pas uniquement pour mon
département il y a eu beaucoup de
remontées
il y a eu beaucoup de remontées
d'ailleurs les problèmes sont tellement
nombreux que précisément le préfet de
l'Orne a installé une hotline ce qui est
en général pas bon signe ça veut dire
qu'il y a quand même beaucoup de
questions qui se posent et l'intérêt si
vous voulez de la question que je vous
posais dont je vous ai annoncé que
c'était évidemment un sujet qui était
évidemment pas majeur par rapport à tous
les sujets que vous avez à traiter et
que vous avez traité aujourd'hui mais il
faut quand même le traiter c'était
monsieur le ministre par rapport à une
circulaire de 40 pages envisager une
différenciation entre les départements
qui avaient inscrites un glisse et ce
qui est votaient au scrutin majoritaire
merci
j'ai donné la parole à notre collègue
Esther Benbassa pour la Réunion
administrative des sénateurs ne figurant
sur la liste d'aucun groupe
vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre Olivier du soft
monsieur le ministre attendez-vous comme
le président de la République que les
Français se lassent ou prennent peur
violence et blessée de part et d'autre
ne se comptent plus cela permet de
remettre la sécurité au centre protéger
les Français et certes un devoir mais il
en est un autre que vous oubliez
toujours les entendre et leur répondre
c'est pourtant simple ils ne veulent pas
travailler deux ans de plus mais leur
colère a d'autres raisons encore plus
profondes plus ancienne je connais les
gilets jaunes pour les avoir longtemps
côtoyés dans les rues de Paris or ils
sont là avec les autres syndiqués ou pas
jeûne et vieux le dépit en bandoulière
la rancune de leurs blessés déjà oublié
dans la tête tous avec ou sans gilet ont
une seule exigence vivre mieux hors
vivre le mieux c'est aussi partir à la
retraite à un âge qui permet d'en
profiter vraiment et plus longtemps mais
vive mieux c'est aussi et traiter
autrement par ce qui vous gouverne
monsieur Macron peut se promener dans
nos régions si lui si le gouvernement ne
change pas la colère ne retombera pas
suffit-il de dire dans un tweet merci
aux travailleurs pour se rapprocher
d'eux la Cinquième République est à
l'agonie votre exercice
ultra vertical du pouvoir la tue le RN
lui vous remercie monsieur le ministre
quand admettrez-vous qu'il faut négocier
et que négocier quand la colère est si
grande c'est aussi savoir céder quand
c'est devrez vous sur un test
inutile et injuste CD n'est pas
forcément perdre
monsieur la parole est au ministre du
Travail du plein d'emploi de l'insertion
monsieur du stop merci à Monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs madame la sénatrice Benbassa
vous dites madame la sénatrice qu'il
faut négocier qu'il faut discuter la
réforme des retraites sur laquelle vous
revenez a fait l'objet d'une
concertation de 4 mois qui n'a pas
permis de trancher tous les différents
nous le savons mes quatre mois elle a
fait l'objet d'un débat parlementaire
ici même c'est une centaine d'heures
débats et à la fin un texte qui a été
adopté avec une large majorité du Sénat
une première fois une seconde fois en
commission mixte paritaire à nouveau
dans l'hémicycle ce texte il est
légitime et il a été adopté de manière
démocratique vous dites il faut négocier
il faut continuer à discuter c'est une
réalité c'est ce que nous allons faire
nous allons faire puisque le président
de la République l'a dit la première
ministre l'a dit aussi il a un certain
nombre de sujets qui relèvent de la gêne
vert social sur les conditions de
travail sur l'emploi des seniors sur le
déroulement des carrières qui a nos yeux
relèvent très directement la négociation
entre les partenaires sociaux il y a des
sujets qui ont déjà fait l'objet de
négociation le partage de la valeur
notamment et nous allons transposer de
manière fidèle intégrale l'intégralité
de l'accord passé par quatre des cinq
organisations syndicales et trois
organisations professionnelles il y a
des sujets sur lesquels nous allons
continuer à ouvrir des discussions et
des sujets qui parlent la loi de réforme
des retraites relèvent du dialogue
social je pense notamment à la nécessité
et même l'obligation désormais dans les
branches professionnelles de négocier
des accords de prévention l'usure
professionnelle qui permettront aussi
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
des hommes et des autres vous dites
madame la sénatrice dans votre question
qu'il y a des manifestations qui
survientes qu'il y a des blessés et
qu'il y a finalement une forme de grande
violence du débat public et de ses
troubles je note deux choses madame la
sénatrice la première c'est que j'ai en
tête des images de vous-même
manifestants il y a quelques mois et par
odian le passage à tabac du président de
la République en donnant des coups sur
une effigie à son image j'ai aussi en
tête la question que vous venez de poser
il y a deux minutes pas une fois madame
la sénatrice pas une fois vous n'avez
apporté votre soutien en force de
l'ordre qui sont mis à dur épreuve et
par vos encouragements au désordre par
vos encouragements au bouleversement pas
vous encouragements aux actes qui
relèvent une forme d'outrance c'est vous
madame la sénatrice qui est un
marche-pied pour le Front national
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames de
Monsieur les ministres merci nos
prochaines questions d'actualité auront
lieu le mercredi 10 mai à 15h je vais
suspendre la séance qu'elle sera reprise
à 16h30 pour l'examen de la propulsion
de loi visant renforcée l'accessibilité
et l'inclusion bancaire la séance est
suspendue